este campamento a las puertas de la
capital de india nueva delhi se extiende
muchos kilómetros desde hace tres meses
miles de agricultores ocupan esta gran
carretera nacional para manifestar su
enojo alrededor del campo numerosos
policías mantienen una presión cotidiana
son los manifestantes para obligarlos a
abandonar su lucha y regresar a sus
hogares nos lanzan gases lacrimógenos y
piedras la policía está detrás de ello
no regresaremos a nuestros hogares
estamos determinados sólo regresaremos
el caso de victoria de lo contrario será
sobre nuestro cadáver y las razones del
enojo tras leyes defendidas por el
gobierno que pretende liberalizar y
regular el sector agrícola del país
en este centro comunitario improvisado
en medio del campo jóvenes y viejos
manifestantes están determinados a no
renunciar del todo en el dow se siente
afectado más suelo los aires de autores
la gente de la ciudad está en día lucha
para nosotros se trata de una guerra una
guerra directa
[Música]
para aguantar a largo plazo los
manifestantes tienen todo previsto baños
farmacia hospital lavadoras bibliotecas
y mucha agua potable y alimentos
los agricultores enojados no tienen la
intención de ceder a la violencia sino
de resistir durante meses hasta que el
gobierno acepte su petición
somos pacifistas y seguiremos así la
violencia y la violencia no nos interesa
nuestro primer ministro no nos responde
y permanece en silencio en su torre de
marfil no da conferencia de prensa ni
entrevistas ni nos miran
casi el 60% de los indios aún trabajan
en el sector agrícola que representan un
electorado de peso en el país bajo la
presión de un movimiento cada vez más
masivo el gobierno en arén dra modi
ofreció varias concesiones pero se niega
a retirar sus leyes agrícolas
apoyamos a los agricultores estamos de
corazón con el 99 por ciento de los
agricultores que no manifiestan y con el
1% que lo hace el gobierno hacen todo
para poner en marcha reformas que casi
todos los partidos políticos reclaman si
los agricultores prefieren continuar con
el antiguo sistema pueden hacerlo es
solo que ahora cuentan con nuevas
opciones ya no están obligados a
venderles solamente a los compradores
del estado
antón así muchos economistas apoyen
estas reformas los agricultores se
sienten ignorados y temen ser
abandonados y quedar a merced de grandes
sociedades privadas y multinacionales la
principal inquietud la supresión de un
precio mínimo de compra garantizado
hasta
por el gobierno algunas cosechas
esenciales potencialmente un enorme
golpe para el 86% de los agricultores
indios que poseen menos de 2 hectáreas
de terreno
además preferimos un precio mínimo
garantizado ya que si las grandes
empresas toman el sartén por el mango
impondrán sus tarifas estoy muy enojado
las familias de los agricultores son
tratadas como criminales eso es lo que
está pasando
en el pasado a los agricultores indios
ya han pagado el precio de la
liberalización agrícola en 2006 en el
estado de biar los mercados al por mayor
manejados por el gobierno fueron
privatizados el estado se retiró sin
invertir los defensores de las nuevas
leyes agrícolas dicen que los
agricultores podrán elegir que el
mercado se abrirá podrán vender sus
cosechas a quienes quieran o al mejor
precio nosotros también el gobierno nos
había prometido eso en otra época que
tendríamos más opciones con una
privatización del sector pero en
términos reales fue a la inversa los
agricultores se vieron acorralados ahora
son los comerciantes locales los que
definen el precio de compra y los
agricultores desesperados no tienen otra
opción que aceptar y si se niegan
pierden sus cosechas los agricultores
que se manifiestan actualmente temen que
el gobierno se retire progresivamente el
sector agrícola y sufran la misma suerte
que los agricultores de viejo
antes los agricultores venían aquí para
vender sus productos pero eso se acabó
los comerciantes compran directamente en
los pueblos a muy bajo precio y aquí los
más grandes se hacen al producto y lo
venden más costoso
tengo que hacer para que esa cartera
de regreso a su pueblo wizard teme que
las nuevas leyes destruyan lo que queda
del mundo agrícola en india
yo lo que querrán hoy en día muchos
agricultores quieren abandonar su
oficina
y ni les hablo de los hijos no me
imagino un futuro para ellos en este
sector
que padre quisiera que su hijo trabaje
en un oficio con el que apenas puede
vivir y satisfacer sus necesidades
la rabia y la amargura de los
agricultores indios parecen desbordarse
así el movimiento crezca difícil
anticipar el resultado de su lucha
[Aplausos]
[Música]